[Music]  Pippa Middleton is reportedly pregnant  as wonderful the Middleton family has  lots to celebrate the 34 year old  socialite and her 42 year old husband  James Matthews are reportedly expecting  their first child together in October  the Sun on Sunday says the couple told  their family and friends just last week  after Pippa's 12 week ultrasound even  more exciting Pippa and her big sister  the Duchess of Cambridge Kate Middleton  are pregnant at the same time we have a  very normal assistant a were nice to  show and the news comes just days before  Kate is due to give birth to her third  child with husband Prince William we  spend a lot of time together we sewed it  together as a family  Pippa and James tied the knot on May  20th of last year at st. Mark's Church  in angle filled  [Music]  [Applause]